muy bien pues buenas noches
me da mucho gusto estar aquí felicidades
a todos los organizadores speakers
es más venía a platicarles hoy este y
después este ya que estuve en tabasco
conecte más con el medio ambiente la
verdad que felicidades por esta gran
ciudad viene este algunos kilos y años
algún tono de tenis cuando tenía
veintitantos y está increíble la
naturaleza la riqueza que tienen como
como ciudadana una gran oportunidad de
región
bien pues hablando de ya de lleno en el
tema del día de hoy yo tengo años
trabajando en temas de sostenibilidad
medio ambiente
y de hecho hace algunos años estaba
en monterrey hay vivieron unos años y
estaba con mis hijos
en un evento de reforestación y tenemos
todo el día y siempre trato de alguna
manera de involucrar a mis hijos en
temas
de voluntariado medioambientales etc y
me dice mi hijo que está un poco cansado
realmente la diferencia está plantando
árboles y me quedé pensando
le platico miles de personas estos temas
por todo el mundo y cómo le hago para
explicarle a mi hijo que si es bien
importante entonces
a lo largo de la plática voy a conectar
con mis hijos y ver un tema tan complejo
como cambio climático cómo podría
conectar más con los hijos o con los
niños o con la gente para que entiendan
lo dramático que es lo que está pasando
y si no hacemos algo diferente pues no
no hay un planeta
entonces quiero motivar y empezar una
cadena el día de hoy a ver si con esto
que estoy haciendo me muevo un poquito
más de 100 personas y lo que se mueve en
redes sociales del evento del día de hoy
entonces con esto en mente hay mucha
gente que todavía piensa no me cambio
climático no existe son tendencias les
toca a los países grandes que contaminen
hacer algo y no es cierto aquí en méxico
tenemos ciudades muy productivas como
veracruz en el mar que si sólo suben dos
grados centígrados la temperatura se van
a ver afectadas empiezas a subir el
nivel del mar en todos los puertos
hoteles
en la actividad turística se ven muy
afectadas 22 grados 3 millones 4 grados
6 millones sólo méxico
por otro lado de nuevo gente nombre su
pega allá en el caribe o pega en otra
ciudad
esto nada más es si las pantallas
también es méxico segura cannes en el
2000 ya de 15 17 tormentas de las más
importantes de la historia del mundo
pegaron aquí cerquita en acapulco y en
la región y todavía siguen diciendo
nombre aquí en a quienes eso no impacta
impacto impacta muchísimo y no sólo el
tema de que acá va a quedar mucha agua
como en la tarde aquí en tabasco está
cayendo por todos lados y lo útil y lo
complicado es que
hay mucha agua donde no queremos y por
otro lado hay gente que quiere sembrar
los agricultores que requieren de agua y
ya no está llegando entonces nada más el
impacto económico de aquí de méxico si
seguimos como estamos es que 80.000
agricultores van a emigrar van a moverse
a otra actividad porque no tienen agua
para cultivar
en la parte de enfermedades entonces es
una vía express más temperatura más agua
pues es terreno fértil para mosquitos
dengue malaria lo que ustedes se pueden
imaginar que produce esta condición por
otro lado en estilos de vida oa nivel de
ciudad es esto la ciudad de méxico hay
viborita no es una montaña rusa es el
centro de la ciudad cada año se estaba
hundiendo 23 centímetros porque estamos
extrayendo mucho más agua como enviando
más agua de lo que se requiere todo lo
que es lo que tolera el manto acuífero
ya se pueden imaginar cómo se siente un
temblor
con estas bases y una sacudida fuerte no
se la recomiendo
por otro lado a nivel de fauna pues
imagínense las tortugas que vienen a
anidar y el agua hasta arriba pues van a
desaparecer y solo es el ejemplo en las
tortugas imagínense los niveles arriba
con otras especies que tenemos en la
región o en el país
bueno entonces de nuevo conectando con
la pregunta que dice que como explico mi
hijo porque es importante y empiezo a
para algunos ejemplos de cómo varios
sectores pueden influir ongs gobiernos
etcétera entonces también hay buenas
noticias y hay otros organismos que han
estado trabajando en estos temas
de hecho la cumbre de la tierra del 92
la cumbre de río por primera vez reunió
a 195 países preocupados y ocupados para
que esta tendencia se moviera de hecho
la imagen de la juventud está esta joven
implorando les recomiendo mucho este
vídeo de que siendo cambiamos como
tratamos el mundo no habrá un planeta
como lo conocemos
río +20 20 años después ahí estábamos de
hecho un cambio muy positivo 20 años
después es que estábamos compañías ong
es mucho más personas obviamente
preocupadas de lo que estaba sucediendo
y de hecho este año fue como el no ser
una base muy sólida para que la copa la
copa es como la cumbre o la cúpula de
las naciones unidas donde todos los
países se ponen de acuerdo en temas de
emisiones entonces aquí por primera vez
hubo un convenio o acuerdo vinculante
donde todos los países firmaron acuerdos
de reducción de emisiones básicamente
los 200 países que estaban ahí se
comprometen a empezar a cambiar
prácticas de combustibles fósiles a
energía renovable y quizás quizás así se
cumplen porque hay países que se han
echado para atrás que no quieren soñar
al día de hoy podríamos revertir la
tendencia
entonces buenas noticias y por otro lado
como les comentaba ahí estábamos y la
gran diferencia es que ya las compañías
nos empezamos a comprometer públicamente
de hecho a mí me dio mucho gusto que
algunas de las de los compromisos que
presente el río
de los temas que más se resaltó a nivel
de ander york times' en su decisión de
domingo donde comprometió femsa usar 85
por ciento de energía renovable
renovable aquí en méxico entonces fueron
fueron ejemplos donde normas y fue
llegar hoy en tu gobierno tu presidente
cambia lo que está haciendo no llegamos
con ejemplos puntuales de cómo se puede
demostrar lo que es sostenibilidad y es
bien sencillo es generar valor económico
social y ambiental de manera simultánea
bien como les comentaba tenemos ejemplos
muy positivos pero no es suficiente
o sea requerimos unirnos como sectores a
mí me da mucho gusto ver tantos
emprendedores el día de hoy aquí porque
de hecho estos retos ambientales se
convierten en oportunidades y de hecho
usted lo leyeron presidió el consejo
mundial del world environment center wec
empezó en el 74 tiene 44 años trabajando
este organismo antes de que el tema
realmente estuviera la agenda mundial
son campeones en el tema son champs
básicamente está este organismo nace
como un organismo de las naciones unidas
del pen uma con un fondo y hemos ido
creciendo cada vez más y no sólo son
compañías que hablan de hacer cosas o
son eso el web que es una estructura de
las siguientes compañías son 27 en este
momento más ong es la academia que
estamos en este momento 27 compañías que
si las sumamos es el equivalente al pib
de muchos países entonces tenemos no
sólo el valor económico haciendo el
valor de marca está imagínense a walt
disney hablando de temas ambientales en
sus películas o ejemplos como los que
siguen podemos llegar a todas las partes
del mundo con eventos o ejemplos
por ejemplo marks spencer
que está en londres gran compañía de
vídeo hacemos eventos para ver cómo
integramos la estrategia a la estrategia
del negocio en el caso de martín
suspensión dado que mejor hemos
colaborado en diferentes foros para
acercar a sus grupos de interés y ver
por qué es inter por qué es importante
para ellos que nos estrategia en este
este trabajar con proveedores o con
comunidad y este en particular a mí me
encanta practicar porque es una de las
compañías del grupo estrella azul que
está en panamá y gracias al web bajamos
fondos del departamento de estado de
eeuu
estamos inyectando invirtiendo en los
ganaderos que nos suministran leche en
panamá básicamente estamos en verde
haciendo la cadena gracias a los
esfuerzos del web
entonces le dije lo de europa de eeuu de
centroamérica de como él trabaja
y aquí me ponía reflexiones de nuevo es
suficiente
estamos avanzando pero no es suficiente
y aquí les doy algunas reflexiones a los
emprendedores y diferentes sectores que
están de cómo podrían sumarse
perdón un dato muy importante antes de
los ejemplos y es como dentro de esta
parte
el primero de agosto que acaba de pasar
por año por año consecutivo volvemos a
agotarlos el medio ambiente mucho más
rack muy rápido de lo que se puede
generar pues es decir en agosto ya nos
acabamos el planeta y lo de agosto y
diciembre lo estamos cargando negativo
no quería darles otro ejemplo este tan
negativo en este momento pero justo es
para darles darles el mensaje de que no
es suficiente y nos estamos acabando de
nuevo el planeta mucho más rápido lo que
se puede regenerar bien ahora sí
ejemplos de cómo podrían cambiar ustedes
la manera como están trabajando o es mi
reto por sector
cada quien desde su trinchera que podría
ser
y bueno como emprendedor que hay aquí
muchas buenas ideas consigan un reto
ambiental un reto en temas de agua
residuos sólidos sólidos energía y que
les apasione y háganlo somos su proyecto
de vida
ustedes como académicos tienen un gran
poder de influir que los jóvenes
incluyan en sus aulas la sostenibilidad
ustedes como empresarios pues les llegan
las cotizaciones
denzel a realmente en un rango económico
razonable al que tenga mejores prácticas
ambientales que se incluyen en su cadena
de valor
ustedes como funcionarios pueden pensar
hoy en hombre este tema desde las
naciones unidas no tengo nada que hacer
no es cierto es todo lo contrario los
alcaldes y gobernadores tienen mucho más
influencia de planea ciudades integrales
las verdes
y que van a influir una manera muy muy
positiva en reducción en la reducción de
emisiones
como ng incluye estos temas además hay
fondos disponibles para trabajar en esos
temas incluyen sostenibilidad en sus
misión y objetivos con buena gente
como medio de comunicación cuando
comunique nada más cuando tenemos
tormentas y huracanes comuniquen
historias como las de hoy de mucha gente
que está hablando estos temas requerimos
mucho más escala y que el mensaje se
comunique que si se puede cambiar la
tendencia
cuando como individuos ésta está muy
fácil usen menos menos agua menos luz
reciclen reducen estás en tu casa sean
campeones de su casa de su colonia de su
edificio de su escuela como individuos
es de lo más importante que podemos
hacer
y bien esté aquí
alguna pequeña pausa y los americanos
dicen oh what the pack predica con el
ejemplo entonces muchas muchas las
palabras a mucha gente pueda hablar y
mueve pero el ejemplo arrastra como les
mencionaba aquí no sé cien personas 100
plus
diferentes hombres mujeres emprendedores
funcionarios públicos y nada más piensen
un minuto en que los motiva que los
mueve ríos y emprendedores y proyectos
y en mi caso son mis hijos y entonces yo
el día de hoy quisiera empezar una
cadena y un compromiso en pro del medio
ambiente y de nuevo me preguntaba
a ver si quiero que mis hijos se le
entiendan y conecte con la juventud como
le haría básicamente les escribí esta
carta
pues que era para ellos nada más
pero al día de hoy a que se lee pues
creo que va a estar en redes sociales y
en algunos foros pero foros públicos
pero básicamente es lo siguiente
a mis hijos pancho alejandré david
son mi inspiración para trabajar en todo
lo que hago por el planeta y quiero
asegurar dejarles un mejor planeta del
que yo recibí
no lo puedo hacer solo para eso
necesitamos de muchas otras personas
organizaciones y empresas pero sobre
todo ustedes y las generaciones que
vienen en camino que serán sus hijos y
sus nietos
estoy muy orgulloso de que les guste
pensar en la conservación del medio
ambiente ustedes deberían estar atentos
pero sobre todo comprometidos también
de todo lo que se puede hacer por él
estén seguros de que toda la pequeña
acción cuenta y les doy sólo unos
ejemplos de lo poderoso que puede ser
multiplicar esfuerzos de los billones de
personas que somos en este planeta para
poder revertir el daño que ya le hemos
hecho por siglos
y allá van algunos ejemplos
no creas que tirar o levantaron a la
shura no importa porque solo es una de
ustedes que va a tratar a la tierra con
respeto
respetar a sus semejantes y trabajar en
armonía para el beneficio de todos
serán responsables de sus actos en este
planeta planten muchos árboles pero
sobre todo inviten inviten a otros a
hacerlo
desde cualquier pequeño rincón actúe en
cada una de las acciones impacta a
nuestro planeta todo cuenta
así que cada cosa que hagan que sea un
favor del planeta que es su casa
en el es tocar a vivir a ustedes y las
futuras generaciones
y enseñarles esto sobre todo con el
ejemplo habrá sido mi mejor elección
pero sobre todo mi compromiso ante
ustedes los quiero mucho y quieran
también mucho su planeta un abrazo
sostenible su papá
entonces
como les mencionaba este es mi mi
compromiso este es mi reto
como comentaba ban ki-moon no hay un
planeta no tenemos un plan b requerimos
cada quien empezar con su cara de
compromisos ese es mi mensaje es mi idea
es lo que quisiera yo el día de hoy
dejarles como mensaje que cada quien
empieza su cadena de verdad el planeta
es de ustedes tómenlo empecemos la
cadena es de todos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]